the compressors have to be mounted
snugly this climate chamber made by the
stoats company in Hamburg will be ready
to send off to England in just a few
days it will be used to cool large
computers in a data center many major US
Internet companies have their European
headquarters as well as their data
centers in Britain that makes the
British market vital to companies like
stores is tomato round 20% of our entire
business is produced in this factory and
that's why Stutz is following the
discussions about a possible break sit
very carefully they see Britain one of
the most important markets for data
centres as vital to their global
business but the arrangements could
change we'll have to see what happens it
all depends on the agreements or
contracts Britain makes with the EU
concerning Commerce and customs then
we'll see if there are any impediments
or if the situation will be like the one
in Switzerland where agreements are in
place concerning business and customs
the port of Hamburg has become a focal
point for discussions about a possible
brakes it cars and machines as well as a
huge range of other goods are exported
from here what's more many northern
German companies have their branch
offices in Britain Siemens wind and
aircraft builder Airbus have large
factories in England
let's be honest discussion for the past
few years business in Britain has
increased and that's why we have to
watch what happens in the past six
months direct investment has gone down
by half since everyone's waiting to see
what happens it's not just northern
German companies that are hesitating to
invest a Britain outside of Europe is
less attractive for other investors too
among them American internet companies I
can imagine that a lot of investments
would be redirected to Europe every
investment includes a data center so it
could very well happen that our business
will move from the island to the
mainland but for the time being still
sis Hamburg Factory is still delivering
1/5 of their climate chambers to
customers in Britain and if business
remains as good as it is now the company
plans to expand their service centre in
London